I believe I have a story which is which
shows us a sign it is the end of time
indeed yes from the AP
ex-ohio Court mediator arrested
allegedly sent feces to GOP please okay
please explain please don't do this
don't Richard Richard Stein steinel a 77
year old from Mogadore Ohio former
Portage County Common Pleas Court
mediator charged with sending injurious
articles as non-mailable violating
federal law that prohibits mailing
certain things including hazardous
materials according to court records
it carries a maximum present sentence of
one year and a 100 000 fine
people have lost their minds
now I do think stuff like this probably
happened all the time with people doing
weird stuff there was also this video of
some woman mailing her period I guess to
like the Supreme Court right yeah now
here's the funny thing she may have
staged it because she films a video and
then it's like it jump Cuts around and
she may be thinking like I want to
actually do it that's gross but by
making that video which doesn't
understand is that you'll still get
charged yeah there were people when they
were a bio weapon well it doesn't matter
if you mailed it if you show yourself
doing something that implies you did
they have to go in and check every
mailbox and they have to like so uh
search for it there was that story of
the woman
who uh licked the ice cream and put it
back yeah and everyone's like but she
bought it right after it's like it
doesn't matter did she though no one
knows that they saw a video for looking
at putting it back and now they have to
come and throw all of the ice cream away
because it's contaminated
so this guy we gotta we're gonna have to
throw away the entire GOP they've all
been contaminated
yeah poop it's not the poop that's
that's bad for you it's the stuff that
grows on the poop oh gosh I'm not sure
it's bacteria it all feels bad future
facts I don't want any of it thrown at
me future scene and cadaverine yeah
interesting molecules you know what is
sad though what did they say the fine is
in here hundred thousand yeah okay
what's sad is like knowing today's
modern left that will be covered in a
GoFundMe
speaking of feces I've received
confirmation of the tilapia
um it says tilapia in the wild feed on
algae but on farms they're reared on
corn or soybean meal however when no
other feed is provided they will eat
poop there have been instances where
fish farms in Asia were found to be
feeding poultry sheep or hog manure to
tilapia oh no wow cool that apparently
is true what is this McGill University
tilapia and the poop connection yeah
great is that is that what you were
reading yeah
so disgusting it's very unscrupulous
operations apparently ooh yeah his aunt
farms around corn however the no feed is
provided they will eat poop there have
been instances where fish farms in Asia
were found to be feeding poultry sheep
or hog manure to tilapia
what do you guys know about gutter oil
oh no yeah wait why is this Vaguely
Familiar I think it was it was like a
viral video a long time ago they in
China they scoop out sewage and they
filter the oils out and then cook with
it oh no on the street
but because they're cooking it does that
mean it's not like infectious anymore
well infectious is it isn't the issue
the issue is like are you eating food
it's like is the oil mineral oil or like
what oil is it yeah they scoop things
out of place what is it what is it yeah
like not all oil is food
that's the oil that people ate before
maybe maybe whether spiritual or not
this is like a sign of the end of days
when we're at the point where we're
recycling manure from animals to feed
fish because we need food to sell maybe
it's like you know rather than to feed
soil we've gone too far we time it to
turn back yeah go back to the to the
good corn harvesting yes there you go
come on seiferts yeah
it's our time to shine yeah but you're
what's interesting is that the pro on
this the the beautiful nature of the
times that we're living in is that
people are waking up and in turn
pursuing a lot of things that help them
prepare for the the whatever days that
we're in also help them fight back those
that really feel convicted to stand up
like they have more resources than ever
the good news is is that we're in a time
where I'll give a perfectly relevant
example to what we're doing on our
platform on Public Square public sk.com
if you want to check it out there's a
group called front yard Farms there's
like a community group where all these
people and it's one of our most popular
groups on the app right now because it's
all these users that are coming in
together that want to learn how to grow
their own food and it's grown by the
thousands in the past few weeks and
that's really neat because what it shows
to me is like okay there's really an
ownership that individuals are taking
over their own existence they are trying
to prepare themselves for whatever is
coming and worst case scenario they'll
need it they'll need to learn how to be
completely self-sustaining because the
world will go so crazy in the United
States the American experiment as we
know it today does not exist in 20 years
like
what we're seeing the best case
scenarios now you know how to grow
tomatoes in your backyard and good for
you you took ownership of your own
destiny and you actually provided for
your family that's amazing when you pull
the Tomato off the vine and bite into it
nothing better oh cherry tomatoes we had
cherry tomatoes growing every morning
I'd go out I'd get fresh eggs in the
chickens cherry tomatoes and peppers and
that that was my breakfast come on but
we learned the hard way we planted all
of our Tomatoes at once
too many tomatoes don't do because then
all of a sudden one day we had like 50
tomatoes and we couldn't eat them you're
supposed to plant one wait a week plant
one way to eat them yeah I don't can
them I don't think we're in the end days
that phrase gets comes up sometimes but
for every one of us these are the final
days because this is our life totally
there will always be an end to our life
so every individual can talk about it as
if this is the end because you only have
this one but we we mean kind of like the
end of this era yeah you know because I
actually don't think we're in the end of
time either my own personal views I
think we're at the end of an era that
the world has looked a certain way and
it's about to change
Industrial Revolution I did hear this it
may not be true but um this is the
dawning of the age of Aquarius oh yeah
22 30 I think is when that begins the
selling of the age of Aquarius that's
right interesting yeah let the sunshine
in you know we're going to be tapping
the vacuum for energy dude do you guys
know what seed bombing you ever heard of
seed bombing no they retrofit C60 bomber
planes oh yeah and they pack them with
seeds like trees saplings and they fly
lie over like deforested areas and just
drop hundreds millions of seeds they
don't plant nearly as well as doing them
by hand but they can drop magnitudes
more of them and they said they can
plant like a billion trees per day wow
levels of terraforming it's gonna be
funny when in like 30 years they're like
we got to cut trees down they're just
too many there's there's no more carbon
dioxide with us for the carbon we need
the carbon yeah dude we're going to be
able to mine and burn carbon and then
grow trees remember Mars remember when
they said to not use paper bags because
it was bad for the forest and to use
plastic when I was a kid that was the
big thing yeah they were like stop using
paper bags they're tearing the forest
down use plastic then like they were
like stop using the plastic bags start
using the paper bags they're getting
pollution everywhere and it's like it's
like for every problem you think you're
solving you're making a new one well
that's a great point because San Diego
actually was a national case study which
is where I left San Diego
um a few years ago they made plastic
bags illegal formally at the city level
in San Diego and what ended up happening
is that the trash crash that homeless
people would leave on the streets in San
Diego got exponentially worse and not
just trash but also like their own human
fecal matter and we try to figure out
why like why on Earth is the trash
um just so exponentially greater than it
was even six to nine months ago and they
tied it back to that policy what used to
happen is that homeless people would put
their trash in their feces in these
plastic bags and would throw it away but
now you have the scenario where you took
away their access to plastic bags and so
the alternative is that we have trash
and feces flooding the streets wow and
so you don't realize with foresight how
these decisions are going to impact you
10 years down the road solar panels is
another perfect example you guys have
Michael schellenberger on huge fan of
Michael read apocalypse never if you
never have fantastic book but Michael
talks about this all the time they when
they go and recycle these solar panels
they go and put them in impoverished
communities in Africa in the land and
then it pollutes Water Supplies like we
don't think about how this the windmills
will affect Eagle populations we don't
so you think you're helping something
and in turn you're actually causing a
really detrimental effect yeah I was
telling you tomorrow I've been working
with this company that pulls carbon
dioxide out of the air and then converts
it into graphene and it the problem that
can come out of that is that we start
pulling too much carbon out of the air
and then we start killing off all the
the plant life but thank God I thought
of that now hopefully you know we'll be
able to mediate and make sure that that
isn't a problem that is Created from the
mining
uh I think it was funny we mentioned the
other day when the wind turbine started
leaking oil yeah and then everyone was
like huh what do you mean yeah it's like
they they I hope they don't do that yeah
yeah they need oil we got a lubricated
man yeah and not just to maintain them
but to produce them in the first place
this is this is this is the challenge
with um
I don't I don't I don't know how you
solve our political issues we have a
great government I mean not literally
today I mean a system of government was
devised by the founding fathers which is
quite brilliant but has devolved into
some Catholic nightmare
and what happens is you get a politician
who's like
doing stuff is hard
saying things is easy that's right and
so they're like we gotta we gotta have
green you know Green is better than
brown or or or or gray or whatever the
cities are supposed to look like they
want the green initiatives not the
machine initiatives
and then what ends up happening is they
say we're gonna we're gonna build wind
turbines and everyone says that sounds
good and then it costs more to do the
return is is is insufficient and then
people think they're doing better but
they're just spending money car is a
good example one Theory going on right
now is that the big push for electric
vehicles is simply because they're
trying to save the Auto industry a huge
portion of the US economy is based on
cars people don't buy cars anymore
there's too many there's so many cars
and they're getting better and better
and they last longer and people drive
less like what do you do
electric vehicles now we're going to get
rid of all the gas ones and go all
electric
that's convenient because it helps uh
keep the the gas for you know machinery
and things like that that you know more
industrial use cases
but I think I think it's likely a big
component is just make electric cars
because now all every everybody's buying
up all the electric cars and they're
hard to come by and there's huge demand
economics not environmentalism thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there